written during the fall of mariupole the
name of Ukraine's Eurovision entry
encapsulates their endurance struggle
heart of Steel
[Music]
it's Andrew and Jeffrey's tribute to
their country not performing there but
in host City Liverpool instead feels
Bittersweet it would be more happier if
this can happen in Ukraine and we didn't
experience the war and full-scale
Invasion but uh
um we want to say a huge thanks to
United Kingdom for hosting it and for
all the support we received this means a
lot to US 23 year old Anastasia agrees
the support has been overwhelming from
the nation she now calls home she's
proudly flying the flag for those who
can't be here I love to see your
pregnant symbol your pregnant flag
Ukrainian colors everywhere I go and I
really feel so warm and hard and I think
so it really supports our culture in in
many many different ways Tatiana also
arrived six months ago this celebration
she says is much needed it's really
important for us to have this moment in
the middle of what's going on to find
this opportunity to celebrate and to be
together tonight is the last round of
semi-finals and the people of Liverpool
are prepared to party in the place of a
nation that wishes it could ashamed